VR is expensive up until recently you
needed at least $1,000 on a VR capable
rig but within these new rx 480 starting
out at $200 it's made baseline VR PC is
much more affordable with that said I
set out to build a $700 VR PC to show
you that you don't need an insane amount
of money to build a vr k bull ring and
yes that includes the hundred dollar OS
because VR is so graphically demanding
our PC is going to need a beefy GPU VR
requires the graphics cards to render
not only at a high resolution but at a
high frame rate consistently above 90
frames per second to ensure smooth
immersive experience at the heart of the
build is aimed these are X 480 GPU which
is built on the company's new Polaris
architecture at $200 it's the cheapest
graphics card designed for VR out on the
market the card features 2300 for stream
processors a 12 66 megahertz of boost
clock and 4 gigabytes of vram it's a
little faster than Nvidia's GTX 970
which is a VR capable card costing $300
plus VR can be CPU intensive especially
when the computer calculates
head-tracking so the rig's brain is
aimed these 8 core FX 8350 it carries a
4 gigahertz stock clock and at $160 it's
the cheapest CPU that meets Valve's VR
requirements the spine of our build is
gigabytes sexily named 978 - UD 3p
motherboard which has the am3+ socket
support we need for our CPU for a little
over 60 bucks
it also offers USB 3.0 ports for RAM we
got a gigabytes of ddr3 memory from
g.skill we could have gone with slower
1366 memory to save a couple bucks but
opted for a pair of faster 1600
megahertz sticks this allows us to run
the ram in dual channel mode for more
bandwidth and despite costing less than
$40 it comes with some nice heat
spreaders for storage we went with a 240
gigabyte course air force le solid state
drive we could have saved money by going
with a cheaper hard drive for more
storage but it makes more sense to add a
hard drive later since you want the OS
on the faster SSD Plus most VR games are
currently made by small indie Studios
and games are relatively small in size
for our case we're housing everything in
deep pools a tesseract chassis the case
is under $40 and doesn't look bad for
the price plus has front USB 3.0 ports
while the case comes in a variety of
colors we opted for one in white
powering everything is EVGA z' 450 BPS
see the former 50 watt power supply is
enough for all of our components running
at stock clocks we'd recommend something
beefier if you intend to overclock
finally the last piece of the puzzle is
the operating system Windows 10 cost
about honor bucks so let's put it all
together
with the computer built up we thought a
good point of comparison would be Dells
XPS 8900 PC which is the already sales
PC includes a GTX 970 GPU an Intel Core
i5 6400 CPU and eight gigabytes of RAM
so how well did hold up in those team
via performance benchmark it scored a
six point seven which is AVR already
score that ensures we'll have consistent
smooth experience for context this is
slightly higher than Dells six point six
score I also ran time spy on both rigs
which is future marks latest benchmark
our build scored three thousand seven or
eighty two here which is nineteen
percent higher than Dells 3167 score
with the benchmarks out of the way we
were able to jump right into VR to shoot
robots and zombies in no time as you can
see from our PC you don't need to break
the bank to build APR ready
you